ولكن من ما تناولناه بالامس في العربيه
360 حول الحديث عن ضغوط امريكيه على
القاده الاوكرانيين لاتخادي موقف اكثر
لينا تجاه المفاوضات مع روسيا اليوم يكشف
مسؤولون امريكيون عن محادثات المكثفه قدها
مستشار الامن القومي
مع كبار مساعدي الرئيس
بوتين في محاوله للحد من مخاطر نشوب صراع
او صح حول اوكرانيا
من استخدام الاسلحه النوويه او اسلحه
الدمار الشامل الاخرى وفقا لصحيفه واستج
جورنا الامريكيه
مستشار السياسه الخارجيه ومع نظيره
الروسينيكولاي باترون شيف ولا هدف
والحمايه من مخاطر التصعيد وابقاء قنوات
الاتصال مفتوحه وليس مناقشه تسويه للحرب
في اوكرانيا
باي مكالمات صالحا واي مسؤول روسي رفيع
منذ مارس الماضي وكذلك فعل الكرملين بعدم
التاكيد
بلوماسيه تقليديه بين واشنطن و موسكو الى
ادنى مستوى منذ الحرب البارده المتابع
للتحركات الامريكيه سيرى ان واشنطن تدير
مسارات الحرب مثلما تدير عمليه المساعده
لاوكرانيا كيف السلاح النووي خط احمر نصر
روسيا خط احمر
وهزيمتها الكامله كذلك
[موسيقى]
لماذا نقول ذلك بحلول اكتوبر 20 21 كانت
الاستخبارات الامريكيه تستعد وعلى معرفه
تامه بان بوتن قرر شن الحرب على اوكرانيا
برنس
الى النوفمبر من عام 2021 لتحذير بوتن من
الغزو تفاجا بتروشيف عينها حينها من معرفه
سي اي اي بالامر وفقا واشنطوس
المسؤول الروسي ان على قوات مسقط توقف عن
مهاجمه المدن والبلدات الاوكرانيه وحذر
الكراملين من استخدام الاسلحه الكيميائيه
او البيولوجيا
الاستخبارات الوطنيه الامريكيه تحضر
بروكسل واوروبا للحرب بينما كان انت وزير
الخارج
يحذر ويجهز المعني الاول بالحرب
اربع قواعد الاولى لا صراع مباشره بين
الجيش الامريكي وحلف شمال الاطلسي من جهه
وروسيا من جهه ثانيه القاعده الثانيه
تواء الحرب داخل الحدود الجغرافيه
لاوكرانيا
تعزيز وحده الناتو والحفاظ عليها والرابعه
هي تمكين اوكرانيا ومنحها وسائل القتال
وبالتالي لا نصره كامل ولا هزيمه كامل كما
اسلفناها ومهما بلغت الازمه تجد موسكو
واشنطن اشياء مشتركه للحفاظ على الاتصال
بينهما ومنها التزامهما بمعاهده نيو ستارت
التي تحد من الاسلحه النوويه طويله المدى
لامريكا وروسيا والتي من المقرر ان تنتهي
في 20 26 وي المسؤولون الامريكيون والروس
لعقد اجتماعات اللجنه الاستشاريه الثنائيه
التي انشاتها معاهده ستارت لمناقشه
تنفيذها وفقا لمسؤولين امريكيين ما كانت
سويسرا الدوله المضيفه التقليديه لمثل هذه
المحادثات قالت موسكو انها لم تعد تعتبرها
دوله محايده لانها فرضت عقوبات اقتصاديه
في اعقاب الحرب الروسيه على موسكو ومع
تشامك هذه الملفات قد يظهر وسيط لم يكن في
الحسبان مصر يدور حديث عن استضافه القاهره
لهذه الاجتماعات في اواخر نوفمبر الجاريه
تحافظ على موقف متوازن بين الاطراف راويه
سواء واشنطن موسكو او موسكو وكاف علاقتها
المميزه قد تكون السر في الاستضافه